I think the inflatable charm a bee
represents the fact that Trump has an
inflated ego is very thin-skinned
doesn't like to be really cooled but
this this humorous symbol is actually a
very powerful symbol that the general
public can get behind and it and it
carries a very serious message we are
Salima helium um we know that helium is
a gas it's a greenhouse gas and quite
powerful gas but but but what
we're doing here is speaking out against
Trump
he's a much much bigger if you mean the
amount of gas is going to go into this
little booth Facebook is pales into
insignificance next to the danger that
transposes to the rights of some of the
world's most vulnerable communities
[Music]
as a British citizen I feel let down
because I feel that we should not be
condoning the kind of policies and
politics that Trump stands for I think
that you know when someone it carries
the kind of the blood on his hands
regarding you know human rights
violations and not only that by
welcoming him here you know in the wake
of breakfast Britain is gonna be looking
to do trick make trade agreements with
with the US and that's a very important
thing to be for us if you do it but is
this the kind of person we want to be
making those trade agreements with and I
think the answer is No
[Music]
I think that Sadiq has spoken out
against Trump and Trump satellites be
challenged
I think CDP's in this room Ellen I'm
sure I feel like that something zooming
it as well I feel like he's just just
focused from the things that Trump has
done and said I think that Indian he
doesn't like to be wrong to nationalize
Italians but you know if if if Trump and
you know Trump Trump's politics he
spoken very vocally about you know what
what he thinks that we should be doing
in this country one of the things that
he he's advocating is the selling off of
our NHS and even also be advocating
policies and politics that would remove
the protections of the more precarious
and vulnerable workers so so you know I
think the city can see that and Trump
doesn't like her I think definitely
really
you